Being an artist,
wanting to make something,
how do we start
with a blank canvas?
I like to start with an idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Ideas come from sensations.
You don't have ideas
without having sensations.
The art is never in the
painting that you're looking at,
or the surface of the sculpture.
The art is inside you.
When the lights at the museum go
off, nothing's happening there.
But within you,
everything exists.
We're going to be speaking
about the ready-made, which
is pulling an object from
its everyday situation
and bringing it into a
context where it could
take on different meaning.
I want to show you the major
building blocks of art.
Color.
Colors carry meaning.
Texture.
I feel my fingers
want to stretch out.
I get goose bumps.
I want more.
Scale.
How big do you
want to make that?
And form.
As we go into the
three-dimensional,
we're dealing with form.
But there are no rules.
Everything in your life
is source material,
and the more you open yourself,
the more meaning you'll
find in every action you take.
There is nothing
special about me.
There's nothing special
about my experiences,
other than they
were my experiences,
and I've embraced them.
Your experiences, your
memories, everything about you,
it's perfect.
The only thing that is necessary
is that you have the confidence
in yourself to follow
your interests,
and to share those
interests with other people.
Everybody that's interested
in being an artist,
the world needs you.
I'm Jeff Koons, and
this is my MasterClass.